- [Narrator] Your business is wasting time
and money performing
routine repetitive tasks
that could easily be automated
to increase speed and efficiency.
Robotic Process Automation
was made for this.
It's a low risk tool that
speeds up routine tasks
freeing your employees
to do higher value work.
RPA has many advantages
but it can't automate
entire business processes
or workflows on its own.
For instance,
what happens when a person
needs to be involved?
Standalone RPA can't automate
complex processes end to end
because humans and bots
aren't working together.
What happens if you need
to change business rules
on the fly, with only RPA,
rule changes often require
an expensive redeployment
that could take weeks,
and even though RPA makes
copying and pasting data faster
and eliminates human error,
what happens when it
encounters unstructured data
and can't organize and store captured data
so your users can find it?
RPA alone is no substitute
for a purpose built
fully automated process,
but when RPA integrates with
other automation software
it's much more effective.
IBM RPA with Automation
Anywhere is bundled
with Digital Business Automation Express,
a set of digital business automation tools
that give you the extra
capabilities you need
when RPA alone isn't getting the job done.
Like workflow capabilities,
that helps humans and automation
coordinate to run complex
processes from start to finish.
Operational decision
management capabilities
that give you the agility
to change rules on the fly
with no downtime.
Automated capture capabilities,
they can understand any source
including unstructured data,
and intelligent content
management capabilities
that help users and bots
locate and access data faster.
Get everything you're looking for
in a Robotic Process
Automation solution plus
the additional automation
capabilities you need
to unlock greater value from RPA.
IBM Robotic Process Automation
with Automation Anywhere.
Learn more today.